Elon Musk went on stage with Dave
Chappelle and the entire audience booed
him because they were in San Francisco
right I believe so I think Dave choked
around like it seems like some people
who fired her here but that was funny it
was funny great line but legitimately
they might be there yeah that's true
like where is Twitter's offices it says
Silicon Valley right probably yeah I
think they got a few offices but yeah
I'm sure they must have one of them if
not them they're homies
we're definitely in the crowd yeah and
also if you go and you go to one of
these like tech companies and you lay
off you know three thousand people four
thousand five thousand people and you
got a bunch of tech [ __ ] that
can afford to go to a Dave Chappelle
Show it's probably all Tech dudes in
there anyway so they're gonna probably
side with the people who work for a big
tech company not the owner of the big
tech company did you see the video no
it's interesting you want to watch like
a couple seconds
man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tears and blues I say
[Applause]
Elon
hey there
[Music]
just gets worse from there but Dave rods
for him Dave like supports him and he's
like nah [ __ ] the people booing like I
mean yeah he brought him there yeah yeah
the people have spoken yeah that's true
but he'd like a couple jokes at him like
at his expense like just like goofing
but then yeah you like wrote for him the
whole time yeah
I don't really get why like what was the
connect what was the link up why would
he want to bring him out just because
it's like a cool dude that I think it's
a fun flex and it's also I'm sure of fun
for Elon to like listen Elon either
enjoys being liked like every other
human being on the planet or understands
the power of of of of of press like
being in The Ether you know he did a
great job of not ever buying a [ __ ]
advertisement for Tesla and simply just
being the mascot for Tesla himself saved
so much money doing that
so the tricky thing is it's hard to be
rich and liked it's even harder to be
rich liked and famous yeah most truly
wealthy people we don't even know their
names yeah
you know what I mean like the Saudis all
dress the same so you don't even really
there's like anonymity in it right 100
yeah there's nothing to do with the
culture it's like how do I be a prince
worth billions of dollars and just walk
around the mall like anybody else yeah
yeah a higher 20 lookalikes that look
just like you walk around the mall
that's it boom everyone's wearing the
same shirt kind of Genius but like you
know we hear these like famous names the
Rothschilds you know the Rockefeller
maybe the Rockefellers lost all their
money but like you hear these famous
iconic names and
you don't really know who they like
who's the Rothschild that's alive now we
knew one of them dated [ __ ] what is
that rapper who never puts out the album
no Exhibit C was the song that was crazy
yeah oh Jay Electronics Jay Electronica
and that's the only reason why she
popped up but these people that are part
of these like Legacy families are worth
all this money you don't know about them
because they've learned what new rich
people have not learned yet because
they're newly rich is that with wealth
comes resentment animosity and hate and
it just makes it harder to keep making
that money so most people who have
Legacy money go I don't want nobody to
know how much money I got yeah it is
better to keep the money and not Flex it
than have the then Flex it and then risk
the entire internet trying to cancel you
yeah I mean look at liver King I think
the only reason liver King is canceled
right now is because he said he made 100
his company's made 100 million dollars
and that number popped up and it was
like hold the [ __ ] on I don't know this
is the only reason but it contributed to
it a lot meaning like that was that was
the the what is it uh the the tip of the
iceberg not even the tip of the iceberg
or whatever it was like that was the the
straw that broke the camel's back but
there's something about money that
breeds if lubricant was out here like
it's really hard for me to make a living
this life is really difficult but I
really believe in it people be annoyed
and be like oh I don't even care if he's
on steroids or not blah blah they might
even be upset about why are you putting
your family through this right a hundred
million yeah that's why one of the most
impressive things Rogan has done is no
one really knows how much the deal is
we're still speculating yeah everybody
else
I don't know how much her deal was worth
you know I mean the things that are a
little
from somehow managed to keep it under
wraps God bless him dude you're smart
100 it's better to keep that [ __ ] yeah
it's bet it's like so I think maybe and
who knows I'm sure Elon is you know
aware of all this I'm sure he studied
all this I'm sure he's crunched all this
[ __ ] data he's he looks at all his
friends that are incredibly wealthy and
I'm sure they go listen it's better
you're not a [ __ ] famous person it
just makes it easier to move around he's
probably calculated all this and he's
like I have so much more influence and I
can move markets if I am a famous person
but I'm going to have all the scrutiny
that I have to deal with I don't know if
it's but my little kids won't have to
yeah but I don't know if it's purely uh
data in like number crunching I think he
also just likes the attention
so so there's the question that's like
which I don't think is wrong but I do
think that as like intrinsic to him we
all want to be liked yeah the question
is what happens when you're experiencing
less like
than hate
and
do you Retreat do you Retreat into the
political party that's more supportive
of you is that what has happened is that
why he went from this like apolitical
cultural figure to this I'm going to be
more right-wing now and the left has
left me and is he really just retreating
back into his supporters because he
wants to be liked yeah or is that
genuinely how he feels and he just felt
like it was time to make a political
statement there's no question that he
likes attention the question is can you
weather the negative attention and
that's hard yeah not everybody's bill
for that especially when you haven't had
that he's been probably most of his life
at this point in the public eye exalted
he really adored yeah like just with the
rocket stuff Tesla like the PayPal [ __ ]
like going through it right now yeah
like with the Twitter [ __ ] he is going
through it I don't think he's ever been
uh hated this much and so I think that
was a play for hey let me go up with
a very popular guy and try to get back
into people's good graces and it kind of
backflies yeah irony is I think I saw
like five million views or something
crazy like that when he pulled it it's
on Twitter
embarrassed you paid 43 billion dollars
to watch himself get embarrassed and it
probably stings more because I'm
thinking you go even if it's San
Francisco you're going on stage at a
Dave Chappelle show you think the
non-woke anti-woke whatever you want to
call them audience is going to be there
and they're gonna support you and when
they boo you that's gotta be like you
yeah that is a great [ __ ] point yeah
you would assume that Chappelle's
audience at least Chappelle's audience
now after all the anti-oh like canceling
they don't like cancel culture you would
think they're like oh we support the guy
who's also against those things and like
liberating this platform from those
things yeah for them to Boo as well yeah
God damn that's just a rough feeling in
general like I don't like reading
negative comments on YouTube and like
the idea of walking out in front of a
stadium of however many people that was
an arena to your point that wasn't like
a comedy club so even if there they know
people who worked at Twitter or whatever
there's 20 000 people there how many
[ __ ] knew somebody at Twitter
really we're about to find out how
autistic he is like because if this
doesn't bother him
confirmed I think I think it does
because he blamed it on like anti-wocal
like left wing whatever and it's like
you know that's not really true what do
you mean like I think Elon said like oh
the people booming me were just he's
like super left-wing anti-woke people
and if you're Elon you know those guys
aren't coming to Dave Chappelle showing
the last show that they're showing up
and also it wasn't a few people yeah
you got a few thousand people yeah yeah
that are hopping on yeah it's it's um
yeah I wonder if he backs away from it I
want we're gonna find out what he wants
more does he want to be successful and
wealthy or does he want to be likes more
and he might find out that it's very
difficult to be both of those things
being unanimously liked and adored the
only person that I can think of that was
both wealthy and unanimously liked and
adored
was Dave Chappelle
and now that's gone yeah now he's a
polarizing figure but he was the last
one that I can look and be like wow
here's a person that had strong opinions
but both sides were supportive they
thought that he was absolutely hilarious
they want to go see his shows
and until the trans thing
yeah it's interesting